When I first started
bringing my kids in the woods,
I wasn't sure how
they take to it.
And it seems like
it's in their blood.
Makes me feel real proud.
[music playing]
Go check out the bath house.
We got some work
to do ahead of us.
Part of having
these hot springs is
taking care of the hot springs.
There's a cold stream that
flows next to the bath house.
What we're going to
do is start working
to get this whole
place cleaned out,
take all the mud out,
and hopefully come
away with a beautiful bathtub.
What we want to do is take
these rocks out here and kind
of divert the stream going in.
We're just getting all
this water to flow through.
And then it'll take
all the mud with it?
Yeah.
Well, not all this mud.
But inside we could
stir it up, and get
that mud and stuff that's in
there on the pallet washed out.
OK.
Let's go inside.
Put on some rubber boots.
I want to teach Skyler a little
bit of community service.
A lot of us use
these hot springs.
A lot of us use this bath house.
And fixing this bath
house is teaching
him how to be a better person.
When it comes to an area,
he leaves it a better place.
Let's see that bucket.
I could fill it up with mud.
You can just carry it.
Out last time this is done
is probably a year or so.
The mud has really built up.
[music playing]
OK.
Well, let's keep taking
loads of mud out of here.
What we want is a sand
bottom not a mud bottom.
Get all this mud up.
Very dark, black mud comes
from deep within the Earth.
And it basically just settles
inside of that bathtub.
What I'm trying to do is take
a good 6 to 8 inches of mud
off the bottom of this
bathtub, so it gets
to clean, clear water inside.
Life's too short
for a muddy bath.
[music playing]
It's getting down to
the sand, though, Sky.
You are?
Yeah.
We are.
You're doing a lot of work.
Skyler is working his butt off.
He's taking these pans of
mud and dumping them outside.
And they're ready to
be filled up again.
Working together like this,
we get a lot of work done.
OK.
Oh!
That was heavy.
OK, Sky.
Looks like we're
about done in here.
We got it down to sand.
All the mud's out.
Good job on carrying
all that dirt out.
With Skyler's help,
we were able to clean
that entryway out
completely of mud,
and it's looking beautiful now.
It looks good.
You want to close that stream
off out there real quick?
Yeah.
OK.
I'm going to dry off.
Shut that cold water down.
We're done with it.
People at home in
the city, they're
using the cold knob and
the hot knob on the faucet
to get that perfect temperature.
That's what me and
Skyler are doing today,
but we're using a creek
and the hot springs
to work out a perfect
temperature in this bath house.
We really blocked
this off right here.
[music playing]
It should be good.
My job in the hot
tub is complete.
[music playing]